aber jetzt habe ich schon die ganze zeit
diesen ohrwurm ein freunde der sonne das
hier wird jetzt kein platter
heilpraktiker verriss weil sie das oft
oder befürchtet habt das ist kein
schwarz weiß thema
sicher ist nur wir wissen zu wenig
darüber von garantieren hat manche sind
heilpraktiker wie kleiner ärzte ohne
kittel und mit mehr zeit mitgefühl für
andere sind heilpraktiker wilde
esoteriker die nichts mit medizin zu tun
aber wie die realität aussieht mussten
wir auch erstmal recherchieren und da
hat mich einiges überrascht also wohl
durch ein tee macht es euch gemütlich
wir steigen durch falls ihr gute
erfahrungen mit heilpraktikern habt
könnt ihr wahrscheinlich ganz gut bei
dieser geschichte ihr mitfühlen also ich
hatte einen ganz schweren autounfall die
nicht wirklich nur durch iris glück
überlebt habe und habe aber fast keine
folgen davon getragen hinweis dachte ich
das erstmal und hat sehr viel später
dann über schwindelanfälle gehabt und
bin ohnmächtig geworden und war damals
ja schon medizinstudentin bin von arzt
zu arzt geschleust worden und in die
uniklinik untersucht worden und man hat
halt am herz an den lehrern am gehirn
überall nichts gefunden
wie gesagt na ja keine ahnung was du
hast und ich bin aber zunehmend
verzweifelt gewesen bin dann zur
heilpraktikerin
auf empfehlung von der kommilitonin
gekommen und die hat gesagt mensch ist
doch ganz klar das hängt mit der
posttraumatischen belastungsstörung nach
diesem unfall noch einem quasi nahezu
tödlichen unfall zusammen
und das war schon also der erste moment
wo ich dachte oh moment warum ich mir
das nicht selbst aufgefallen und deshalb
vielleicht schon eine so große
erleichterung gebracht dass ich mich
auch endlich selbst wieder verstanden
habe und das als angststörungen oder was
dramatische störung zuordnen konnte und
dann natürlich auch die besser damit
umgehen konnte
und die hat mir dann noch nie gegeben
sagt er
wieder kommt nimmst du dir einfach und
damit hatte ich plötzlich auch ein tool
in der hand und siehe da innerhalb von
wenigen wochen waren die beschwerden weg
das ist doktor natalie gramms sie ist
ärztin und sie war als erz den auch
homöopathie für mich hat es damals so
eine art erweckungserlebnis gewirkt und
ich dachte wow das ist ja so toll dass
man sich unbedingt lernen
doch inzwischen gehört sie zu den
wahrscheinlich prominentesten kritikern
der homöopathie und auch das
heilpraktiker berufs warum sie diesen
prozess durchlaufen hat werden wir im
laufe des videos noch erfahren vor
müssen wir aber noch ganz kurz klären
was heilpraktiker eigentlich genau
machen ausübung der heilkunde ist jede
berufs oder gewerbsmäßig vorgenommene
tätigkeit zur feststellung heilung oder
linderung von krankheiten leiden oder
körperschäden bei mensch das ist einiges
in dieser umfrage zweier
heilpraktikerverbände waren 2017 knapp
60 prozent als heilpraktiker im bereich
psychotherapie tätig der rest im bereich
naturheilkunde psychotherapie
naturheilkunde sind ja bereits zwei sehr
unterschiedliche bereiche und
naturheilkunde kann alles sein ich
glaube es war eine ganz typische
heilpraktikerin nie hat ein
unglaubliches kompliment von methoden
gemacht sei das jetzt stopfen oder
akupunktur oder chinesische heil massage
und die hatte aber auch so geräte mit
elektro magnetresonanz keine ahnung mehr
was wo dann irgendwelche schwingungen in
meinen körper geleitet werden sollten
und es war auch alles überhaupt nicht
gegeneinander abgegrenzt
[Musik]
das sind die top 10 im bereich
naturheilkunde laut umfrage
wissenschaftlich betrachtet kriegt man
dann natürlich leichten reizhusten
homöopathie zum beispiel in den 200
jahren seit es sie gibt ist es trotz
unzähliger anläufe nicht ansatzweise
überzeugend gelungen nachzuweisen dass
homöopathie besser wirkt ist eine
placebo behandlung
ich finde da kann man sich langsamer
damit abfinden dass sie das auch nicht
tun
ansonsten verweist noch auf dieses video
wo wir demonstrieren was in globuli
wirklich drin ist verlinkt infokarte
haben wir noch entgiften die talks
heißes ob instagram ist auch mehr
fantasie als wissenschaft also für
echtes die talks braucht man nur zwei
sachen nämlich eine gesunde leber und
gesunde niere über akupunktur müssten
wir mal ein eigenes video machen alles
andere würde dem thema nicht gerecht
werden aber so viel sei gesagt es ist
wissenschaftlich umstritten andere dinge
dieser liste sind so vage formuliert
schmerztherapie ernährungstherapie
gesundheits und prävention beratung dass
man die wissenschaftlichkeit hier nicht
pauschal bewerten kann hat mir fest
wissenschaftlich fundiert steht hier
nicht unbedingt an erster stelle das
heißt wohlgemerkt nicht dass alle
heilpraktiker von allen
wissenschaftlichen geistern verlassen
sind der heilpraktiker ist macht nicht
automatisch wurde genauso wie eine
ärztin nicht automatisch
wissenschaftlich arbeitet es gibt ja
auch erste die zum beispiel homöopathie
anwenden wie wird man heilpraktiker die
heilpraktiker prüfung um als
heilpraktiker tätig zu sein braucht man
keine approbation also keine staatliche
zulassung lisi ärzte zahnärzte oder
psychotherapeuten vorweisen müssen und
bei psychotherapeuten ist das ziemlich
verwirrend denn während den meisten
wahrscheinlich klar ist dass
heilpraktiker keine ärzte sind ist der
unterschied zwischen einem
psychologischen psychotherapeuten und
einem heil praktischen psychotherapeuten
den meisten laien wahrscheinlich nicht
besonders klar weshalb aktive arbeiten
zu dürfen braucht man eine
heilpraktikererlaubnis dafür muss man
eine prüfung beim zuständigen
gesundheitsamt ab wie sieht diese
prüfung aus laut dieser info broschüre
des verbandes deutscher heilpraktiker
sehr schwierig irgendwie macht mich
diese einschub eher misstrauisch als
dass er nicht überzeugen
kaum ist das war genau an die prüfung
besteht aus einem schriftlichen und
einem mündlichen teil der schriftliche
besteht aus 60 multiple choice fragen
von denen 45 richtig beantwortet werden
müssen da wären zum beispiel
verschiedene krankheitsbilder abgefragt
im mündlichen teil der prüfung findet
man zum beispiel hier
gedächtnisprotokolle es gibt fragen zu
gesetzeskunde zu verschiedenen
krankheiten und fallbeispiele wo die
prüflinge erzielen müssen wie sie diesen
patienten behandeln würden wieder
scheint sehr vernünftig allerdings
fallen diese prüfungen von
gesundheitsamt zu gesundheitsamt sehr
unterschiedlich aus denn es gibt keinen
geregelten prüfungsstandard da das
zuständige gesundheitsamt vom wohnsitz
abhängig
findet man zum beispiel in
facebook-gruppen immer wieder den tipp
einen wohnsitz oder praxisraum anderswo
anzumelden oder ähnliches um die prüfung
dort abzulegen nach bestandener prüfung
davon aber deutschlandweit als
heilpraktiker aber die ist diese prüfung
also sehr schwierig darüber streiten
sich heilpraktiker befürworter und
heilpraktiker gegner gern worüber man
wahrscheinlich nicht streiten muss ist
dass man mit 60 multiple choice fragen
und einer möglichen prüfung nur so viel
ab frank an klar das ist aber eigentlich
gar nicht der springende punkt wenn ich
das jetzt vergleich mit chemie studium
da bestand die diplomprüfung auch nur
aus vier mündlichen prüfungen ab 60
minuten ja ich bin alt ich hatte noch
diplom was mich mehr interessiert ist
was passiert vor der prüfung was muss
ich vorweisen um die prüfung ablegen zu
dürfen
in meinem fall waren das zum beispiel
acht semester chemie studium mit
etlichen klausuren mündlichen prüfungen
laborpraktika die man bestehen musste
scheine sammeln man kennt es passiert
also vor der heilpraktiker prüfung
welche ausbildung gibt es ja freunde der
sonne genau hier liegt der hase begraben
der hund der hase im pfeffer wissen was
ich mal um zur heilpraktiker prüfung
zugelassen zu werden muss ich an
ausbildung lediglich einen
hauptschulabschluss vorweisen mehr nicht
im sommer gibt es noch irgendein beruf
im gesundheitswesen krankenpflege
rettungsdienst geburtshilfe wo man keine
fachliche und praktische ausbildung
vorweisen muss ohne eine fachliche
ausbildung kann die heilpraktiker
prüfung keine fachliche eignung
überprüfen egal wie schwer sie ist und
da sage ich das ist offiziell im rahmen
der heilpraktiker prüfung muss kein
nachweis einer allgemeinen
fachqualifikation erbracht werden die
leipziger prüfung ist eine
unbedenklichkeit prüfung oder notenskala
und keine fachprüfung sie fragt keinen
bestimmten ausbildungsstand ab deswegen
ist sie genau genommen also formal auch
keine prüfung sondern nur eine
überprüfung diese überprüfungen dient
ausschließlich dem zweck festzustellen
ob die ausübung der heilkunde eine
gefahr für die volksgesundheit bedeuten
würde
das heißt mit der konkret beabsichtigten
heilkunde tätigkeit eine gefahr für den
patienten verbunden wäre
also ich weiß nicht wie ihr das seht
aber wenn ich krank bin und deswegen zu
jemandem gehe habe ich ein bisschen
höhere ansprüche als dass er mir nur
nicht schadet nochmals so wichtig ist
laut heilpraktikergesetz dürfen
heilpraktiker feststellung heilung oder
linderung von krankheiten leiden oder
körperschäden durchführen voraussetzung
dafür ist die bestandene heilpraktiker
prüfung also überprüfung nur stellt
diese heilpraktiker überprüfung gar
nicht sicher dass man krankheiten
feststellen heilen und lindern kann
sondern dient ausschließlich dem zweck
festzustellen ob eine gefahr für die
volksgesundheit besteht wie kann es sein
dass eine prüfung nur so viel ab fragt
man danach aber so viel machen darf ich
will natürlich nicht behaupten dass
heilpraktiker automatisch schlecht
ausgebildet sind es gibt viele die zum
beispiel eine therapeutische ausbildung
haben und dann einfach noch die
heilpraktiker prüfung oben drauf sitzen
oder es gibt auch heilpraktiker schulen
die ausbildungen anbieten
laut dieser broschüre wird vor der
prüfung im schnitt eine dreijährige
ausbildung absolviert das problem ist
nur diese ausbildung ist halt nicht
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben es gibt zwar
prüfungsleiter auch solche
fortbildungszertifikat aber nichts davon
es verbindlich und nichts davon wird
kontrolliert ich denke das ist doch auch
nicht im sinne der heilpraktiker ich
habe zum beispiel mit einem
studienleiter einer
praktiker schule gesprochen der mir
erzählt hat wie sie eben schulinternen
die qualität sicherstellen dass er sich
aber auch verbindliche standards für
alle wünschen würde und dass er es gut
fände wenn man zum beispiel eine sammeln
müsste um zur prüfung zugelassen zu
werden das heißt eine qualitätssicherung
ist nicht nur im interesse der patienten
sondern auch im interesse aller
heilpraktiker die ihren beruf ernst
nehmen also sehe ich das richtig dass
alles dafür und nichts dagegen spricht
dass heilpraktiker nicht nur diese
überprüfung vorweisen müssen die ja nur
sicherstellen dass man keine gefahr
sondern eine gescheite fachliche
ausbildung
da sind wir uns einig oder es gibt zwar
eine berufsordnung für heilpraktiker
darin wird aus dem urteil des
bundesgerichtshofs zitiert solange kein
ausreichendes medizinisches fachwissen
und können erworben wurde dürfen keine
methoden angewendet werden deren
indikationsstellung also deren auswahl
oder risiken sonst eine medizinisch
wissenschaftliche ausbildung erfordert
doch verstöße gegen die berufsordnung
haben nicht etwa dieselben konsequenzen
wie bei ärzten
verstöße können bestraft werden vorher
sollte jedoch immer der versuch einer
kollegialen bereinigung durch die
zuständigen berufs vertreter unternommen
werden
man kann auch aus dem verband
ausgeschlossen werden was ein aber nicht
daran hindert den beruf weiter auszuüben
auch hier ist also wieder alles nur
unverbindlich gut nächster punkt wenn
heilpraktiker zumindest dazu ausgebildet
sind keine gesundheitlichen schäden
anzurichten
dann gilt ja für den gang zum
heilpraktiker das motto kann ja nicht
schaden oder heilpraktiker dürfen manche
tätigkeiten ausdrücklich nicht ausüben
sie dürfen zum beispiel keine
geburtshilfe leisten sie dürfen keine
infektionskrankheiten bei anderen
generell keine meldepflichtigen
krankheiten zb auch kein coup 19
doch alles was nicht explizit verboten
ist ist erlaubt so darf ein
heilpraktiker zum beispiel krebsleiden
behandeln während ein hausarzt einen
krebspatienten zum onkologen
weiterleiten würde was einfach nur
also im negativen sinne nun geht es mich
ja nicht an wenn ein krebskranker
menschen eben seine behandlung noch zum
heilpraktiker geht und sich bachblüten
geben lässt oder wenn jemand bewusst
eine medizinische behandlung ablehnt zum
beispiel eine chemotherapie hier soll
nicht die freiheit in frage gestellt
werden selbst über den eigenen körper zu
entscheiden nur gefährlich wird es wenn
man eine medizinische behandlung in dem
falschen glauben ablehnt das alternative
heilmittel besser wirken wie zum
beispiel bei dieser 18-jährigen sie
bekamen einen bösartigen knochenkrebs
behandelt wurde sie mit geistheilung und
homöopathie keinen wirksamen medikamente
noch nicht einmal schmerzmittel und
dieser krebs ist sehr schmerzhaft drei
jahre später starb
abgemagert und mit metastasen in libanon
eine konventionelle planung ist bei
dieser krebsart mit einer über 70
prozentigen wahrscheinlichkeit
erfolgreich und hätte ihr zumindest
schlimme qualen erspart und es geht
leider noch krass 2016 verabreichte ein
heilpraktiker in einem krebszentrum am
niederrhein drei krebspatienten den
experimentellen wirkstoff pro büro war
ein stoff der zwei im labor hoffnung
geweckt hatte aber noch nicht als
medikamente zugelassen war
als wäre das nicht schon hart genug
wurde das präparat von heilpraktiker
selbst gemischt obwohl er nun nicht
einmal eine ausreichend sensible waage
dafür hatte so dass er den drei
patienten eine überdosis verabreicht und
sie so tötete es gibt natürlich auch in
der medizin schreckliche und tödliche
unfälle und fehler und fahrlässige
tötungen
es macht nur für mich schon unterschied
ob wir zum beispiel ein chirurg bei
einem riskanten eingriff versagt oder
eine ärztin bei einer komplizierten
behandlung bei falsche entscheidung
trifft oder ob der fehler ganz klar auf
fehlende ausbildung und fachkompetenz
zurückzuführen ist wohlgemerkt ist
dieser brom privat fall ein dramatischer
einzelfall der nicht repräsentativ für
die heilpraktiker branche stehen sollte
um gottes willen und inzwischen wurde
das gesetz verschärft und solche
behandlungen sind für heilpraktiker
erlaubnispflichtig was mir aber zu
denken gibt
dass diese drei patienten der behandlung
mit diesen experimentellen wirkstoff
zugestimmt haben
und ich frage mich einfach angesichts
der schockierenden fahrlässigkeit des
heilpraktikers ob diese patienten
wirklich angemessen informiert und
aufgeklärt war frei sein durch
informiert sein
wir alle wollen als patienten gut
behandelt werden aber was ist eigentlich
eine gute behandlung die ärzte haben zum
beispiel unsere leitlinien
da wird gesagt das ist dann sozusagen
stay doch die art wie behandelt man
diese und jene erkrankung denn
wissenschaftlich gesehen am besten
und wenn man davon abweicht muss man das
gut begründen können vor sich selbst vor
dem patienten und natürlich im zweifel
auch mal vom staatsanwalt und das gibt's
bei heilpraktikern überhaupt ich das
heißt gibt noch nicht mal ein maß an dem
eine gute heilpraktikerbehandlungen
gemessen werden können und das hängt
natürlich damit zusammen dass bei
heilpraktikern nicht wissenschaftliche
methoden sehr gängig sind denn methoden
gar nicht erst auf wissenschaft
basierenden natürlich auch nicht so was
wie eine evidenzbasierte leitlinie und
deswegen finde ich es sehr wichtig
zwischen wissenschaftlichen und
nichtwissenschaftlichen methoden klar zu
unterscheiden
ich möchte auch gar nicht dass die nicht
wissenschaftlichen methoden verboten
werden was ich möchte ist transparenz
das was ich tue es aufklärung das wird
oft wahrgenommen als bashing als hexe
als gemeinheit
aber das was mir eigentlich ein anliegen
es ist die gute behandlung von patienten
patienten und darüber möchte ich eben
klarheit schaffen in dem sinne dass man
wirklich weiß worauf lasse ich mich ein
wenn ich zum beispiel die homöopathie
für mich nutzen möchte oder wenn ich zum
heilpraktiker oder zur heilpraktikerin
gehe ich möchte dass niemandem verbieten
ich möchte auch niemandem vorschreiben
die mich zu erklären weil ich glaube
dass man wenn man alle fakten hat auch
tatsächlich nur dann eine freie
entscheidung dafür oder dagegen treffen
kann und es gibt gute gründe sich für
eine heilpraktiker behandlung zu
entscheiden die nicht so menschliche
humanmedizin zeit zu hören zugewandtheit
das ist alles mangelware im
medizinischen alltag ein ausführliches
gespräch mit dem patienten kann bereits
medizin seien die ergebnisse aus der
forschung liegen
das zeit für den patienten die
sogenannte sprechende medizin kein ich
habe mal wohlfühl extra ist so dann
tatsächlich messbar die behandlung und
die wirkungen der medikamente
beeinflussen rund verbessern kann
dank placeboeffekt ärzte beschweren sich
selbst oft dass ihr honorierung system
ihnen nicht genug zeit für die patienten
ist letztlich ist das ja auch meine
motivation damals gewesen zum
heilpraktiker zu gehen ich habe mich
einfach nicht gesehen gefühlt und ich
glaube dass man in dem bereich wirklich
sehr viel mehr leisten kann ich meine
wir sprechen immer von humanmedizin und
lassen das menschliche so hinten
runterfallen das ist super schadet ein
arzt konnte natalie von ihren
beschwerden befreien
der erfolg kann erst nach ihrer erfahren
mit der heilpraktikerin und was ihr aber
letztlich gemacht hat war vielleicht
eine gute gesprächstherapie wofür sie
gar nicht ausgebildet war also sie war
glaube ich einfach menschlich schwer in
ordnung aber sie hatte in ihrem
postkasten gar nicht irgendwie therapien
oder maßnahmen die das irgendwie ja auch
gute weise oder auch wissenschaftlich
gute weise begleitet hätten
und dass ein schaden wie kann man das
jetzt gewesen die gesagt höhere
anforderungen an die ausbildung und
strenge qualitätskontrollen sind ein
wichtiger punkt aber wie kann man einen
sinnvollen weg finden nichts
wissenschaftliche methoden zu erlauben
ohne dass die gefahr besteht dass
patienten sie als medizinisch
missversteht ergänzen nicht ersetzen ich
stelle mir immer so vor dass man
eigentlich so eine art umschulung zu
einer art ich sag mal genesungs
praktiker vollziehen könnte vor allem
auch dann wenn bekannt ist dass ist ja
vielen menschen gut tut und menschlich
wenn sie zum heilpraktiker gehen
und ja dann müssten sozusagen
heilpraktiker aber von ihrem anspruch
kurativ also heim tätig zu sein ablassen
aber sie können wir stattdessen
wohltuend im sinne der patio der sind
der linderung von symptomen tätig sein
und dann können sie an der stelle von
mir aus auch gerne aromaölen geben oder
eine klangschalenmassage
machen die kommen dann einfach der
wissenschaft und auf der
wissenschaftlichen medizin gar nicht
mehr in die quere und heilpraktiker
wollen es auch gar nicht zumindest laut
bund der deutschen heilpraktiker auf den
dramatischen brom privat fall reagierte
der bund etwa mit diesen worten die
heilpraktiker sollten unsere bemühungen
stets komplementär
niemals jedoch als krebsbehandlung oder
als alternative krebstherapie verstehen
oder unseren patienten gegenüber so
kommunizieren es gibt derzeit nicht nur
aus unserer sicht keine gesicherte
alternative zur schulmedizin und auch
hier argumentiert der bund deshalb
praktiker eben keine alternative zur
medizin sind sondern medizinische
therapien begleiten können oder sich um
menschen kümmern die als austherapiert
gelten und so all dem kann ich nur sagen
ja genau und dann hat mich vielleicht am
meisten überrascht an der recherche
nämlich dass sich beide seiten an diesem
kernpunkt anscheinend ziemlich einig
sind nämlich dass heilpraktiker als
begleitend und lindernd tätig sein
sollten und nicht als ersetzend die
frage ist jetzt nur welche regeln es
braucht damit es in der praxis auch
verantwortungsvoll und korrekt umgesetzt
was meint ihr was für regel oder gesetze
wären wichtig damit menschen sicher und
transparent von auch nicht
wissenschaftlichen aber wohl tuenden
methoden profitieren können und habt ihr
erfahrungen mit heilpraktikern wenn ja
teilt sie gerne wenn nein wehrt ihr
vielleicht eher dazu bereit einen
genesungs praktiker aufzusuchen stadt
ein heilpraktiker
ich bin sehr gespannt darauf eure
kommentare zu lesen und schaut nochmal
unten in die video beschreibung dafür
lege ich euch natalies podcast gramms
sprechstunde der podcast für recht gute
medizin wo sie die erstaunlich spannende
schnittstelle medizin jura erklärt da
gibt es auch eine interessante folge
über heilpraktiker und das
heilpraktikergesetz in der endzeit wenig
ich euch noch unsere video fünf
missverständnisses zum placebo effekte
placebo effekt wird nämlich ständig
sowohl unter als auch überschätzt und
ich verlinke euch ein video von terrex
löschenkohl es hat nämlich eine sehr
coole neue kollegin nehme ich die
astrophysikerin und angehende
astronautin dr susanna
sie erklärt euch wie man astronautin
wird schaut er gerne mal vorbei und
hinterlasst ein paar kekse
wir sehen uns in zwei wochen bis dahin
bleibt sicher